today I am going to tell you about the
parallel postulate in Geometry well let
me start by telling you what it is right
so this originally appears in Euclid's
elements it's I think published 300 BC
it's what we inherited as geometry
right and it was in fact for a very long
time especially in the 19th century
taken to be the example of what it means
to know something
right we like it because it's deductive
you know you have a set of rules and
then from those rules you derive some
truths so what is the parallel postulate
and this is something that we're
actually learn in high school geometry
if we are given a line in our plane now
here we have a point P point that is not
in the line then what we can do is we
can we can draw many lines that go
through that point P but what Euclid
told us and that was the parallel
postulate is that there's a unique line
that does not intersect L and goes
through the point P one and only one one
and only one that is that is the key
here one and only one
there exists one and it is unique
and that's what we took to be true that
seems to me like the most obvious thing
in the world right because if I draw any
other line it's got that slight angle
which means it's going to be at one side
of it is going to be tipping towards L
right right and in fact you know like so
this is a little bit of a lie because if
you open Euclid's element you're not
going to find this statement the way it
is written so in fact the way he wrote
it is more similar to what you were
saying what he said is you know if you
have a line and then you have the point
P you draw your line through P then let
me draw just any other line through p
through hell what he said is if the sum
of these two angles is less than 180
degrees then the lines once you extend
them to Infinity they're going to
intersect right classic Euclid parallel
postulate true to me yes exactly exactly
and it well in fact it seems true to you
and to most of us because it is actually
true but it sort of depends on the model
of geometry that we're considering right
so here we're working on a plane and to
the geometry we need among many other
things a way of measuring distance and
you know like if we're here in the plane
we measure distances with a ruler or if
you want you know like there's a formula
if you have coordinates
um it's basically the Pythagorean
theorem so
we know what we're doing
however that is not the only space in
which we can do geometry not even
two-dimensional space right so the plane
we have a vertical Direction
and a horizontal Direction those are our
two Dimensions right let me show you
another space where we can do geometry
here's what we call a sphere so as
mathematicians call it S2 if you're a
mathematician then you draw R3
three-dimensional space and you say that
this is the set of points that are at
distance one from the origin if you're
not a mathematician you're just looking
at the Shell of a football ball is this
a two-dimensional spacer this is a
two-dimensional space because again we
basically only have two directions in
which to move right so if you want we
can
do it in terms of meridians and latitude
right the way we do it to describe
location right like if you look in
Google Maps if you want a precise
location you're going to get two
coordinates yeah exactly that okay so
although although we think of bowls and
things as three-dimensional objects
because we're only dealing with the
shell it's a two-dimension exactly yeah
and that is very important we're not
thinking about the feeling where you
know that we're thinking about a little
ant that is just completely flat
so what happens to the parallel
postulate here well so
you know here I started by telling you
there's a line under
right so I
so the the same thing here I have to
Define my objects so a line in here is
going to be what we call a grade Circle
what is a great circle take the
intersection of this sphere with a plane
that that goes through the origin so
this is a great circle or you know the
way I drew it here this is the equator
that's also going to be a great circle
so every line has to like to be the
longest possible line does it it can't
be just a little circle aha so that's so
this is key right so there's a
difference between what we call a line
and what we call a line segment
right and actually so that line segments
that's one of the first rules that we
have in euclidean Geometry or in in the
geometry of the plane which is that if I
give you two points you're going to be
able to give me a line in our plane
geometry that's pretty easy two points
we get a ruler here's the line right
pretty easy we know how to do it here
a little trickier but is is not so bad
if you choose a point say over here and
then maybe a point over here then how do
I find the great circle that goes
through them right and and I need to
find the great circle and then only look
at that little segment that connects
them and that's another that little
segment well we can do it
um
by choosing
you know like we can extend these points
join them to the origin there's a little
space in between them let me fill that
with a plane
that's the plane that's going to
intersect my sphere
is going to be something like that so
you're trying to find the equator
basically that on which both of those
lines sit exactly exactly except you
know like it's a tilted equator right
like it's not but yes that is basically
it I could have I mean it could have
cheated and just chosen two points in in
the equator but
but so what I drew here is a line right
so the line segment well we have two
options this very clearly short one but
then there's another one that is longer
and it goes around
sometimes what we say is that a line
segment is the segment that whose length
is less than
half of the entire circumference that
fixes some issues so what does this mean
for the parallel postulate excellent
question
so let me do let me draw my sphere here
again I'm going to draw a line that is
easier for me again this Meridian that's
my line
so this is my line L and then I'm going
to get my point P like let me choose
this point P right so lines that go
through P there's this one so here we
have a problem right we have this
intersection in this intersection so
maybe we need another one right okay so
maybe maybe we draw the line segment or
the whole line that goes through p and
then another point over here
okay we draw it
not good no good so it turns out that
what happens in the two sphere is that
there are no parallel lines so before we
say that in the plane
there existed one and it was unique so
here we don't even have that first part
of existence we're done okay but I mean
that's not that's not Euclid's fault he
wasn't talking about no no no no no no
no no absolutely not it's actually kind
of interesting because there was a lot
of research being done in in the
geometry of the sphere or trigonometry
maybe to be more precise because people
needed this for navigation
and for astronomy or astrology for some
people too you know like everything that
had to do with the skies was as fear so
there was a lot of knowledge but somehow
nobody thought that we could think about
these two spaces as similar as both
sharing a set of rules right
it wasn't until maybe later that we in
the 19th century that there was
an upheaval in Geometry when we realized
that in fact if you consider the first
four postulates of Euclid
there are older models where you can do
geometry that holds you know that has
those four rules except for that fifth
one so that so his first four rules hold
up in other spaces yeah this is the one
that doesn't transfer across yeah it may
you know maybe to be precise uh it might
be a modern restatement of
his Axiom sort of postulates right like
we we had to get rigorous the one model
or the one geometry that people started
to think about to show that the parallel
postulate was just not true in general
was
not spherical geometry but hyperbolic
geometry this is going to be a disk let
me draw the center and again I have to
tell you what it means to have a line so
a line it's either going to be a
straight line that goes through the
center or if I move a little bit away
from the center it's going to be the
segment of a circle that is orthogonal
to the boundary circle of the disk so
are there parallel lines right
well in this case we are going to have
parallel lines where we're going to have
too many
so that's sort of like the other problem
right like we said there exists and is
unique we already saw a place where they
do not exist now we have one where they
do exist but they're not unique so
what happens here is
um so let me say again that this is my
line L why not and let's say this is my
point p
well that's one line that goes through P
doesn't intersect L great but I can draw
I can sort of move my circles I could
just do many many more because in fact
they're going to be infinitely many so
the length here again you know going
back to this distinction between a line
segment and a line this circle is a line
it sort of looks like it's like finite
right like here a line is like the one
that extends forever the way we measure
distances here is such that if you have
two points that are very close to the
Border these two points are very very
very far away from each other even
though you know like we're looking at it
and if we were using the distance
measurement that we had in in the plane
they look very close to one another but
the way we measure things in this new
geometry makes them be very far away
this postulate has file this again
yes exactly except you know it failed us
um in the sense that it it doesn't hold
right so that immediately means that it
it is not a consequence of the first
four rules which was actually a question
that people had for a very long time
could it be derived from the first four
postulates
and now we see that's just not the case
and clearly this fifth one was a bit of
an add-on it's not part of the family
it's not a part of the family no no not
exactly and in fact can they can the
other four be derived from each other no
no no no no those are sort of you know
like the the four of them are the
minimal set of rules that you need
um to play the game of geometry if you
want yeah but you know like in fact in
in Euclid's elements if you analyze it
you know like maybe in a philosophical
or historian of science way you realize
that Euclid Waits a while before using
the parallel postulate right he uses the
first four
back and forth back and forth but the
the fifth one he waits a little bit that
was a clue
that's what some people think yeah so
maybe that he wasn't easy about it a
little bit does the does this make you
feel more affectionately towards the
fifth one or less affectionate towards
it do you think of it as an ugly
aberration or does it make you feel it's
more Charming
I think is well I don't know if Charming
but you know like it's a lot more
important right because it just allows
us to think of more than one
way of doing geometry in two dimensions
that's that's just fascinating
the angle is less than two right angles
it's not catchy it's
cheese there's a lot of words wordy and
let's let's see what it means two
straight lines for instance we're going
to put a third one in